prosecutors say Enrique tario was the
top commander of the far-right extremist
group that on January 6 2021 saw itself
as Donald Trump's Army
tario was not physically present at the
riot that delayed the Congressional
certification of Joe Biden's win the
prosecutors say tario orchestrated the
attack recruiting lieutenants monitoring
the assault and privately telling others
later make no mistake we did this
octario served a four-month jail
sentence in 2022 for another offense
telling reporters on his release that he
was unrepentant for January 6th but some
of the guys
that are in there for the j6 stuff
they're going to be in there for a while
they're political prisoners and I'm more
worried about them than I was worried
about myself that tune changed after
tario's May trial in which a federal
jury convicted tario and three other
proud boys leaders of seditious
conspiracy
tario told the sentencing judge on
Tuesday that January 6 was a national
embarrassment and said the trial had
humbled him the judge gave tario 22
years the longest of any Capital Riot
conspirator while we respect the judges
sentence we respectfully disagree and
but yet we respect it there will be a
day and a time where an appeal will come
and we expect the appeal to come soon
tario flashed a victory or peace sign as
Federal Marshals led him away to prison
another proud boys leader who'd been
sentenced last week said he hoped Trump
would become president again and pardon
him here there was a serious attempt to
stop the peaceful transfer of power and
it's a Hallmark of American democracy
and I think there's a lot of concern
among government officials especially
with President Trump out there still
screaming about election fraud that we
have an another presidential election
coming up in 2024 and we want to make
sure that we don't see a repeat of 2020
the U.S justice department has charged
more than 1100 January 6th rioters and
says it continues to make new arrests
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera